PLACE AND ESTABLISHING A PEACE
ACADEMY MODELED AFTER MILITARY
ACADEMIES TO PROVIDE FOR YOUR --
FOR YOUR CONCENTRATIONS IN PEACE
EDUCATION SO MAYBE SHE WILL COME
AND TALK TO WES, MARY WILLIAMSON
AND THE PEACE DEPARTMENT.
WE ARE PRETTY PEACEFUL HERE.
THIS IS PETE "THE STORY," MONDAY
AUGUST 19TH BUT THE STORY GOES
ON AND ON AND WE WILL SEE YOU
TOMORROW NIGHT AT 7:00.
HAVE A GOOD NIGHT, EVERYBODY.
TOTAL GOOD EVENING WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT, ONE OF
THE MORE POIGNANT MOMENTS OF
BARACK OBAMA'S PRESIDENCY CAME
AT THE VERY END, JANUARY 2017
JUST DAYS BEFORE OBAMA LEFT THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE AWARDED
VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF FREEDOM
AND YOU MAY HAVE REMEMBERED IT
BUT OBAMA SPOKE GREAT LENGTH
ABOUT THEIR PERSONAL FRIENDSHIP
AND HE PRAISED BIDEN'S
LEADERSHIP AND IN RESPONSE
BIDEN SAID HE KNEW NO MATTER
WHAT HAPPENS, OBAMA WOULD ALWAYS
BE THERE FOR HIM.
WATCH.
>> IT WAS EIGHT AND HALF YEARS
AGO I CHOSE JOE TO BE MY
VICE PRESIDENT.
THERE HAS NOT BEEN A SINGLE
MOMENT SINCE THAT TIME THAT I
HAVE DOUBTED THE WISDOM OF THAT
DECISION.
JOE'S CANDID, HONEST COUNSEL HAS
MADE ME A BETTER PRESIDENT AND
COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
>> MR. PRESIDENT WE KNOW THAT I
WILL BE THERE FOR YOU, MY WHOLE
FAMILY AND I KNOW THAT IT IS
RECIPROCAL.
>> Tucker: YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO
BE OBAMA TO APPRECIATE THAT
THERE WAS SOMETHING SWEET ABOUT
IT.
IT WAS ALL FAKE, IT TURNS OUT
AND IN THE END OBAMA WILL NOT BE
THERE FOR JOE BIDEN AND IN FACT
HIS INTERNAL FRIENDSHIP HAS
ENDED AND DIDN'T MAKE IT THROUGH
THE NEXT PRESIDENTIAL TERM BUT
INSTEAD OF HELPING HIS TRUSTED
FRIEND RUN FOR THE PRESIDENCY,
OBAMA HAS REFUSED TO ENDORSE
JOE BIDEN.
ACCORDING TO SOME REPORTS OBAMA
REPEATEDLY URGED BIDEN NOT TO
RUN.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THIS HE
WARNED BIDEN.
OBAMA, IT TURNS OUT, CARES ABOUT
ONE THING, HIMSELF.
HE IS OBSESSED WITH HIS
POLITICAL LEGACY.
EVERY DAY THAT WILL BIDEN --
BIDEN STAYS ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL HE DETRACTS FROM THAT,
WHY?
DON'T BELIEVE THE POLLS.
THE POLLS SAY JOE BIDEN IS A
RUNNER AND AS OF TODAY, HE STILL
LIVES.
THE POLLS TELL YOU HE'S GOT A
GOOD CHANCE OF BEING THE
PRESIDENT.
BUT THAT IS NOT REAL.
BIDEN IS OFFICIALLY STILL IN THE
LEAD AND YET, LET'S BE
COMPLETELY HONEST.
BIDEN'S CAMPAIGN IS NOT A REAL
CAMPAIGN, IT IS A ZOMBIE EFFORT
AND LURCHES FROM ONE BLUNDER TO
ANOTHER UNTIL FINALLY SOME
CATASTROPHE WILL PUT IT OUT OF
ITS MISERY.
EVEN BIDEN'S OWN ALLIES WANT HIM
TO STOP SPEAKING IN PUBLIC SO
OFTEN, WHY?
WHEN PEOPLE SEE JOE BIDEN, THEY
REALIZE HE'S NOT A DISTINGUISHED
ELDER STATESMAN, HE IS SADLY A
FADING ONE.
HE THINKS CORY BOOKER IS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
HE BELIEVES THE TRUTH OUTWEIGHS
THE FACTS.
HE THINKS HE WAS VICE PRESIDENT
LAST YEAR DURING THE
PARLIAMENTARY.
WATCH.
I WASHED WHAT HAPPEN WHEN CAME
UP TO SEE ME WHEN I WAS
VICE PRESIDENT.
SOME OF YOU COVERED IT.
>> Tucker: SO MOMENTS LIKE
THAT DON'T MAKE JOE BIDEN A BAD
PERSON, BUT IT DOES MAKE HIS
CAMPAIGN LOOK LIKE WHAT IT
ACTUALLY IS, A JOKE, NOT A
SERIOUS PLAY IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
IF BIDEN WERE OFFERING SOMETHING
REAL, A COMPELLING MESSAGE HE
COULD GET ELECTED ANYWAY, BUT
HE'S NOT.
HE IS IN FACT A DEMOCRATIC
FOSSIL RUNNING FOR THE PARTY
THAT SEES HIM AS TO MAIL, TO
PALE AND TOO STALE.
BIDEN IS OLD ENOUGH WITH PUBLIC
VIEWS PRIOR TO THE YEAR 20080 IN
AMERICAN POLITICS AND THAT MAKES
HIS OLD POLICIES TOTALLY
UNACCEPTABLE TO THE PARTY'S
VOTERS.
1995, JOE BIDEN SUPPORTED ALL
KINDS OF THINGS CURRENT
JOE BIDEN WOULD NEVER ADMIT TO
SECURING COME AS A SECURE
BORDER, DRUGS OFF THE STREETS,
CRIMINALS IN PRISON EVEN.
WATCH THIS.
>> MADAM PRESIDENT, WE HAVE
PREDATORS ON OUR STREETS THAT
SOCIETY HAS, IN FACT, AND
BECAUSE OF ITS NEGLECT, CREATED.
AGAIN, IT DOES NOT MEAN WE
CREATED THEM THAT WE SOMEHOW
FORGIVE THEM OR DO NOT TAKE THEM
OUT OF SOCIETY TO PROTECT MY
FAMILY AND YOURS FROM IT.
THEY ARE BEYOND THE PALE OF MOST
PEOPLE.
BEYOND THE PALE.
>> Tucker: BEYOND THE PALE!
NOW IT IS BIDEN HIMSELF WHO IS
BEYOND THE PALE.
THE CURRENT DEMOCRATIC PARTY
BELIEVES IN FRINK CRIMINALS,
PROTECTING CRIMINALS,
CELEBRATING CRIMINALS AND THE
NEW REALITY BY RELIC OF THE
PAST AND ALL THE ENERGY WITH THE
OTHER CANDIDATES AND INSURGENTS
LIKE ELIZABETH WARREN,
BERNIE SANDERS, KAMALA HARRIS.
ONE OF THESE THREE WILL RISE
ABOVE THE REST AND TAKE THE
NOMINATION BUT IT WILL NOT BE
JOE BIDEN.
ALMOST EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT NOW.
THAT IS ALL BAD NEWS IF YOU ARE
BARACK OBAMA AND IF YOU REALLY
CARE ABOUT IS YOUR OWN CHERISHED
LEGACY.
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN EXPRESSIVELY
RUNNING AS A CONTINUATION OF
BARACK OBAMA'S AGENDA.